[Musique]
ce petit sondage prouve une chose sur
cinq personnes interrogées 4 vous
connaissent
depuis combien de temps vous êtes là au
bord de la route près de bayonne sur la
nationale 10 10 10 ans
et du matin au soir ici au bord de la
route nous tricoter ouais pourquoi un
peu parce que parce que ça me plaît ps
j'aime ça
mais c'est votre métier non c c'est un
jeu un jeu
vous avez d'ailleurs sur vous un très
beau boulot vers vous l'avez tricoter
vous même ouais
mais comme vous tricoter depuis dix ans
vous avez dû faire beaucoup de tricot
tous les tricots que vous faites ne sont
pas pour vous non je ne pourrai clients
j'en ai fait un virage serré vous avez
beaucoup de clients jeunes et oui
beaucoup ils viennent d'où vos clients
de bayonne biarritz
de tyrosse de normandie aussi vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure bretagne de
bretagne près il ya aussi des parisiens
l'été oui
mais en disant au bord de la route ici
vous avez dû voir l'état de chose vous
n'avez pas des souvenirs
ce qui est des gens assez étonnant
qu'ils sont venus vous voir
faire
oui
on m'a dit que le prince de galles était
venu vous voir pour vous commandez un
tricot c'est vrai
c'est vrai il ya un terrain tellement on
est jeune et qu'on est pas tout vous
connaissez pas tous
mais quel plaisir voutré vous trouvez en
tricotant
ça m'amuse
j'aime ça et puis ça fait plus ça fait
plaisir aux gens vous fait plaisir de
travailler pour les autres ça m'a fait
plaisir de travailler pour les autres
les gens sont contents et un médecin
alors vos vaches là sont derrière dans
le pré oui au lieu de les de les garder
en ne faisant rien fait cela oui et je
fais ça paie samassa ministre et ça faut
pas s'arrêter et le soir lorsque vous
rentrez chez vous vous tricoter encore
faire un peu oui
on m'avait même dit que vous tricoter
regardant la télévision oui un peu alors
est-ce que vous avez une spécialité ce
que vous avez des points à vous oui
surtout
des points à jour et que j'aime beaucoup
et que les clients aiment aussi
c'est vous qui avez trouvé ça oui je
vais gérer relève assurée catalogue
et j'ai réussi
j'ai essayé après défenseurs sont mes
tricot
vous êtes abonné à des journaux de mode
enfin pas beaucoup pas beaucoup mais
j'éprouve surtout le modèle paris où il
ya quelques points de très courts qui
sont intéressants qui sont intéressés et
qui paie qui plaisent aux clients
ça vous rapporte beaucoup d'argent
en faire un peu oui
vous ne faites pas que des poules au
vert non je fais des bas des gains
et d'autres choses en tricot quoi par
exemple je fais des chaussons les
chemises américaine à aa
qu'est ce que c'est des chemises
américaine
[Musique]
vous avez 36 ans voudriez encore
tricoter combien de temps au long d'un
temple et peut-être
[Musique]